vuelta al mundo varios agentes de
policía frente a una escuela listos para
intervenir la escena se desarrolla en
connecticut en 2012 frente a la escuela
primaria sandy hook un joven de 20 años
acababa de matar a 28 personas entre
ellas 20 niños entre los 6 y 7 años el
tiroteo masivo tuvo un profundo efecto
en eeuu y enfureció al ex presidente
barack obama cerca del final de su
mandato en el año 2016
evitar más encumbrados kers de 10 mm
en 2018 el estado de texas se puso de
luto tras un tiroteo en la localidad de
santafé donde un estudiante de 17 años
asesinó a ocho de sus compañeros
d
meses antes otro tiroteo sacudió a eeuu
en parkland cuando el día de san
valentín nicolás cruz de 19 años disparó
un arma automática en una escuela de la
que estaba excluido provocando la muerte
de 17 personas
después de cada tiroteo se reanudó a un
sensible debate sobre las armas de fuego
durante un discurso el ex presidente de
donald trump fue interpelado por el
padre de una víctima
mientras sea presidente siempre
protegeré su derecho a la segunda
enmienda a tener y llevar armas
qué pasó conmigo al reafirmar nuestra
herencia como nación libre en 1999 el
tiroteo de columbine fue uno de los
primeros en eeuu en ser filmado por las
cámaras de vigilancia de una escuela en
las pantallas de sus televisores los
estadounidenses conmocionados
descubrieron un fenómeno que no cesaría
en el futuro